lance corporal riley mccollum was a baby
when the war in afghanistan began
as it ends he'll return home as one of
its final casualties
like 22 year old corporal hunter lopez
another one of the 13 americans killed
in the attack on kabul airport and
sergeant nicole g 23 years old all of
them according to their families
fulfilling the dream of serving their
country
and from the pentagon confirmation of a
drone strike that is the retribution
that was promised two high-profile isis
targets
were killed
and one was wounded
and we know of zero civilian casualties
without specifying any future plans i
will say that we will continue to have
the ability to defend ourselves
and to leverage over the horizon
capability to conduct counter terrorism
operations as needed isis may have lost
in in this strike they lost a planner
and they lost a facilitator and they've
got one wounded uh and the fact that two
of these individuals are no long longer
walking on the face of the earth that's
a good thing it's a good thing for the
people of afghanistan it's a good thing
for our troops and our forces at that
airfield and i think i'm just going to
leave it there they've said it won't be
the last either with another isis attack
on kabul airport said to be highly
likely and the drawdown of the 5 000 u.s
service personnel in kabul has now begun
the operation is in its final days the
space for evacuees dwindling
the president's immediate focus was on
the storm heading for the u.s coast but
his handling of the withdrawal from
afghanistan continues to attract
criticism
it certainly is going to be a really
difficult situation to manage at home
and otherwise and those people who are
already saying he needed to handle it
differently to do more will say see we
were right and those who said
you should have pulled out right away
and should be out of there we'll say
that also so it is a very challenging
situation for him
biden believes the bigger picture ending
what's been called america's forever war
is what americans still want as they
have done for years and whatever the
terrible short-term cost it will be
worth it in the long run
those who did make it out continue to
arrive on american soil a happy ending
for them that so many thousands more can
still only dream of
and the door is closing greg milam sky
news washington